first I'll focus on it right I mean I
think like you basically get what you
spend your time doing right I mean I
want the company to build three products
this year and we're gonna work on a few
others because people are interested in
them but those are the three things that
I'm spending my product time on right um
you get what you put into it if you
spend a third of your time trying to
make the people around you better
through getting better people mentoring
getting them to be better getting the
best people in your organization and
you're known to more impactful roles and
I think over time not just a cruise and
you get a better organization we've had
this tradition for seven or eight years
at the company where every week we have
a QA where our employees can come and
ask me any question that they want about
what's going on and what the what the
direction of the company is or questions
or things that they read about in the
press or that their friends who use the
product
what would their asking them and um and
it's been this really important
tradition for us both because we really
believe in an openness and communication
and that's kind of what Facebook is all
about but it's also really important for
for me and for running the company to be
able to get feedback right and and to be
able to learn what's on people's minds
what our what our employees and folks
who were who were part of our team are
thinking about and and just kind of a
lot of the time there are good questions
that people ask that changed the way
that we that we think about what we're
building and what we're here to do in
the world and that often make us go
think and reevaluate how we should be
approaching different problems you just
watch two amazing clips of Mark
Zuckerberg take the next three minutes
and sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]